hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update this one's for you call of
duty fans who are still on the fence
about picking up a new console if you
still haven't upgraded to a ps4 or Xbox
one from the previous generation
Activision is using its clever skills of
temptation to get you to buy call of
duty advanced warfare regardless and
another act of good faith when you buy a
digital copy of the game on either Xbox
360 or Playstation 3 you'll get the xbox
one or ps4 version for free activision
announced the promotion earlier today
similar to what it did with call of duty
ghosts late last year except this time
there is no ten dollar upgrade p of
course with all good deals comes a catch
you'll have until March 31st 2015 to
purchase advanced warfare if you want to
get the free extra copy for your other
console and you have to buy the digital
version of the game another important
note this offer will not work if you
switch platforms between generations but
it does work both ways within the same
platform in addition to the free upgrade
you'll also be able to transfer your
multi player stats gear as well as
downloadable content you've purchased
from your previous generation versions
of advanced warfare including the season
pass to claim your xbox one or ps4 game
simply log into the same account as you
made the original purchase on and browse
to the game on your consoles respective
marketplace advanced warfare launches on
November fourth but to stay up to date
on the game including news and features
stay tuned to gamespot com
you